only needs to glance at Wild hearts for
a moment to see the similarities it
shares with capcom's monster hunter
series both games are about exploring
large open areas either alone or with
other players to find and defeat giant
monsters then harvesting and using their
parts to craft better weapons and armor
developer omegaforce has explored the
genre before with the tokidan series and
those two games represent perhaps the
best examples of the Monster hunting
genre outside of capcom's own
influential best sellers with wild
Hearts omegaforce hasn't just set out to
create a simple imitation though sure it
has plenty of familiar elements but the
novel karakuri system gives the game a
unique identity that sets it apart from
its contemporaries
in the fiction of wild Hearts karakuri
is an ancient technology used by hunters
to conjure impressive pieces of
Technology out of thin air in action
it's a fast-paced crafting system that
serves multiple functions opening up
your available options both in and out
of combat you start with what are known
as basic karakiri the first of which
lets you produce a wooden crate that
launches you into the air when you climb
on top of it you can stack up to three
of these crates at once to generate
extra height which proves useful when
exploring the environment but really
comes into its own when fighting wild
Hearts various monsters known as kimono
you can launch from these crates and
transition into a devastating downward
strike or utilize the added elevation to
quickly avoid an area of effect attack
that spews out of a pool of lava or
poisonous Cloud erecting these karakuri
is quick and simple so it doesn't take
long before you're integrating the
various devices into each combat
encounter you can also summon gigantic
bouncing hammers powerful bombs and
blinding firework cannons that can knock
flying enemies out of the sky
there's something immensely satisfying
about creating an apparatus out of thin
air and using it to gain an advantage
over a 20-foot tall monster and to the
presence of these multi-faceted tools
doesn't dilute the tension that's
inherent in the genre either each one
costs a specific resource to build
called Celestial thread if you run out
you can find more by hacking down trees
and rocks or by extracting chunks of it
by targeting weak spots on a kimono's
body this ensures that you need to think
strategically and consider when and how
to use karukuri but it also offers extra
encouragement to play with other people
because you can pool all of your
individual resources together both basic
and fusion karukuri are liable to break
one match with the full force of a
kimono but there are a plethora of
dragon karakuri that persist throughout
the entire game unless you opt to
dismantle them yourself instead of using
Celestial thread these constructions
pull from Dragon pits that are locked on
each of the game's four Islands by
unlocking them use their resources to
materialize bigger tools like zip lines
wind vortexes and giant wheels you can
clamp it inside and drive placing these
traversal tools in the world makes
subsequent hunts faster but you can also
place them in other players sessions and
they can do so in yours even if you're
not playing with someone else at that
exact moment something they built
previously might still leave a mark on
your hunt aiding your success long after
they've Departed the moment-to-moment
impact of wild Hearts karukuri mechanic
is already terrific but adding a
societal value to some of the
constructions elevates it even further
foreign
[Applause]
magical gizmos to assist you on the
hunch you're wielding one of eight
distinct weapon types to deal damage
these deadly accoutrement range from a
Nimble Katana to a hefty mall and a
robust hand Cannon and each one has its
own idiosyncrasies including unique
weapon gauges that allow you to inflict
heavy damage when a certain requirement
has been met by attacking and Performing
combos with the katana for example a
gauge fills up that when full lets you
trigger Unbound mode transforming the
sword into a bladed whip that deals
additional damage for a short period of
time elsewhere the karakuru staff can
mutate between five different forms most
of these weapons are rather
straightforward with a couple of
exceptions but any lack of depth is
alleviated by how they synergize with
the various karakuri crafting the
starting version of each weapon type is
also relatively cheap and there's a
training area that explains how to
perform each attack and special move so
wild Hearts makes it easy to experiment
learn and decide which killing tool is
right for you the weapon upgrade tree is
fairly restrictive however forcing you
to fight the same low-level monsters
over and over again before you can craft
some of the more powerful armaments
whatever weapon you choose wild heart's
action is thrilling if not familiar
there's a palpable sense of weight
behind each weapon swing and you need to
consider when to attack so you're not
locked into an animation when you need
to roll out of danger slicing off
Monster Parts is always gratifying and
the orchestral score conveys a sense of
wonder and Terror in equal measure often
evoking classic japanese Cinema with its
use of traditional instruments which
contributes to each battle's
awe-inspiring nature
[Applause]
of course the kimono themselves play a
pivotal role in how enjoyable it is to
cut them down to size each one is a
giant mutated version of familiar
Wildlife crucially these rampaging
beasts are also fused with nature able
to strike at you with fettered fungus
spores and twisting roots that violently
emerge from the ground each kimono
presents a different Challenge and
learning the best strategies to take
them down is a rewarding experience that
encourages the full use of your
extensive repertoire the monster designs
are solid from a visual point of view
but this isn't commonplace across the
rest of the game there are some
beautiful sights to behold but also
plenty of others that fail to flatter
due to the abundance of low resolution
textures and a general blurriness I
mentioned this because despite
appearances wild Hearts also struggles
when it comes to Performance my PC
exceeds the recommended system
requirements yet stuttering and frame
rate issues were a nuisance throughout
my Play Time thankfully these hitches
didn't occur quite as often during
combat but I still encountered a few
moments where the game would freeze for
a few seconds at a time lowering the
graphical settings didn't alleviate
these technical shortcomings either
since it still performed the same at
both the lowest and highest presets a
couple of updates have already yielded
minor improvements and the Megaforce
says more fixes are on the way so the
hope is these issues will soon be a
thing of the past
let's see
the core gameplay Loop of wild Hearts
doesn't deviate too far from the formula
established by Monster Hunter yet the
surprising decision to center it all
around a fast-paced building mechanic is
a stroke of Ingenuity the karakuri
system elevates each individual part of
wild Hearts combat traversal and Co-op
are all improved by its presence and the
way karakuri is weaved into each
component there are some notable
shortcomings that hold it back
especially when it comes to technical
performance but wild Hearts is a welcome
entry in a genre that's otherwise
dominated by a single series
thanks